Speaker 1: Let's get back to hearing from
the most important people in our ecosystem,
the audience. We do take these calls for the
Friday show. We do it via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. And you can join what is
called the waiting lobby. Let's go to Alex from
Vienna now. Alex, is that Vienna, Austria, or is
it like, you know, Vienna, Idaho or so? I don't
know that Idaho really has a Vienna, but it.
Speaker 2: Thanks for taking my call. No,
it's Austrian. Vienna, Austria. Have you
called in before? No, it's my first time.
Speaker 1: Your first time? Okay.
Speaker 2: Well, welcome. Yeah.
So therefore, I'm a little bit nervous.
Speaker 1: You're doing great. So far. You've
stated your name and where you're calling from
beautifully. And that's an auspicious beginning.
Speaker 2: Perfect. Thank you
so much. So, Ivan, our question,
how can we left from left Prox improved because
I think it was in the United States. That was
it. Gavin Newsom said something like
that that the leftists have to be more.
Um. Pop populists.
Speaker 1: I don't
remember Newsom saying more populist. What
I remember Newsom saying is Democrats and
the left need to be more ruthless. We need to be
unabashed. We need to, you know, but to to. That
was the gist of his comments, as I recall them.
Speaker 2: Okay. Yeah, something like that. Yeah.
In Austria, we had a similar discussion. I mean,
a divorce six, six or seven years ago by Peter
Piltz. He was from the Green Party and he tried
this approach and he was an overall really good
person who tried to. Yeah, I can hear. Sorry.
Speaker 1: You're doing great. Yeah. So. But
so is your. Is your question about
whether this is a good strategy?
Speaker 2: Yes. And how to improve?
Speaker 1: Listen,
we it's in the United States. Democrats aren't
really doing this yet. They're not being ruthless,
to use Gavin Newsom's word. So I don't know if
it's a good strategy. What I can tell you, Alex,
is the status quo is not working very well. And
even though the left is right on so many issues,
we're losing the discussion on a lot of those
issues when really we should be winning because
we actually are on the right side of the issue.
So it's very plausible that changing how we talk
about these issues is a great starting point.
And I like the idea of Gavin Newsom now. Will
it work? It's a that's a predictive statement.
We have to try it and see. Hmm. Hmm hmm.
But listen. What? What do we have
to lose at this point? You know?
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah, for sure. Because
the the pilots on the right are, you know,
they're sealing the the the topics. Yes.
And manipulating them. Something like that.
Speaker 1: 100%. I mean.
Speaker 2: We can do that as
well in a positive sense with say yes and and not
just being in the defense all the time that that
same position I've got in my own country. Yeah.
Speaker 1: I am with you and I hope to visit
Austria soon. I was supposed to right before the
start of the pandemic and then we all know what
happened. And I would like to get back. I want
to go to Vienna. I'd like to go to Salzburg. I
want to be all over the country.
Speaker 2: I'm great. Yeah,
I might be again in the States this year.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, then I'll miss you. I guess
that's too bad. All right, Alex from Vienna, Thank
you for the call. Thank you. Thank you. Very,
very good. Did an excellent job. Excellent job.
Let's go to Is it pronounced Jacqui? Is Jacqui
is am I pronouncing that correctly? Jacqui,
is. Are you with us? Jacoby is you're on,
but you have to select the correct audio
device. Last chance for Djokovic is to fix
your audio. Are you there, Jacqui? Is Jacqui is
is gone. That's too bad. Sad. Quite, quite sad.